es ist noch mehr wochen der wahrheit
relativ erholsam einmal genossen und
hätte früher als glaube dass musik sie
alles aufbieten war frühstück und noch
ein exzessiver existiert in irland ist
ein oder zwei kammern und kjaer durch
und wir sind jetzt einfach was der
verstand und raum ist und bevor es
wieder zu erklären
[Musik]
wir lassen kein großer runde kanada
stunde 20 glaube ich angebracht und es
ist ja in drei leistungsgruppen für den
strafen für die mitglieder für die
schwachen
[Musik]
gestern noch mal so oft das erste mal in
den ganzen hauptteile auseinander
genommen und am anfang denkt da war es
dann zum schluss wieder zusammen geht
aber funktioniert relativ gut und dann
hat die kameraden höfen solches
reibungslos abkommen die einzelnen
hauptteil auseinandernehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
beim sterben noch hinten von kathrin
system rechts und sonst wo die nazis
blockieren sie zu hause sind
[Musik]
alonso 4 die neuesten produkts ihre
hemmungen erhebung durch
[Musik]
[Applaus]